we we have to do more to make sure that
the existing measures that we are taking
are having the effect that we want so
it's crucial that people understand
tomorrow that the schools are closed and
tomorrow you shouldn't send your child
to school unless you've been identified
as a key worker and more generally in
view of the way people have responded
over the last few days to the measures
that we have set out I want to say a bit
more about how we interact out doors and
of course I want of course I do
people to be able to go to the parks and
open spaces and to enjoy themselves it's
crucial for health for mental and
physical well-being but please follow
the advice and don't think that fresh
air in itself automatically provides
some immunity you have to stay two
metres apart you have to follow the
social distancing advice and even if you
think that you are personally embalmer
about there are plenty of people that
you can infect and whose lives will then
be put at risk and I say this now on on
Sunday afternoon Sunday evening I take
this advice seriously follow it because
it's absolutely crucial and as I've said
throughout this process we will keep the
implementation of these measures under
constant review and yes of course we
will bring forward further measures if
we think that is that is necessary